Khloe Kardashian defends her gorgeous  bod hi guys i'm lauren zima khloe  kardashian just cannot get a break for  years she was critiqued for her weight  Khloe has even revealed stylist would  not dress her back then saying that she  was too big and now Khloe is getting  hate for being too skinny Coco has been  working on her fitness a ton lately and  she just tweeted never would I have ever  thought I would be in the media for  being too skinny  what on earth it seems Khloe's  referencing some hate she got for  looking slim at her grandma MJ's  birthday party this week and yes it  seems some people weren't making  comments on Twitter well I think Khloe  looks amazing she's actually my fitness  Idol right now let me know what you  think of the comments about Khloe on  Twitter I'm at Lauren's